hello in my opinion there's a
fundamental difference between study
studying and learning being able to
speak a language is a skill a skill that
is acquired with time and by over time
through trial and error do you remember
the first time for example that you
magically started to find your balance
on the cell of your bike
well riding a bike is more or less not
exactly the same thing as language
learning but it is also a skill that you
acquire by trial and error by practice
by practicing as much as you can
I do remember that when I found the
after so many frustrating efforts I when
I found a my balance on the saddle of
the bike it was like the magic and I was
like going around it was so happy it
cannot actually fathom how fathom oh I
had finally managed to ride a bike
I was very impatient and looking forward
to it so I just said I remember very
well I remember very clearly that I was
crying and I was telling myself oh never
I'll never I'll never make it and I do
remember that my father told me just be
patient and it will come and it came and
he did it did come and I was happy about
it now
let's suppose that my father had been my
father is actually an engineer but let
let us suppose that he was very very
passionate about dynamics about physics
and let's suppose that he had thought
that the best way to teach me to ride a
bike was through theory not only you
know put him in putting pointing his own
his own son and us out of a bike but
also trying to teach him how some
physics law some physics laws of work
now I found an interesting piece on the
Wikipedia on dynamics of by thine and
how to find the balance in general it's
pretty long but I'm just going to read a
small and chunk I'm going to here the
rider for
how to reach how to acquire how to find
the balance this this famous balance
that made me so happy when I was seven
seven or six I don't remember exactly it
says here the writer applies torque to
the handlebars in order to turn the
front wheel and so to control leaned it
so to control lean and maintain balance
at high speeds small steering angles
quickly moved to the ground contact
points laterally at low speeds larger
steering angles are required to achieve
the same results in the same amount of
time because of this it is usually
easier to maintain balance and high
speeds now there is no sane person who
would actually teach their son by
teachers on how to ride a bike by given
by giving them lectures on physics
that's true
riding a bike is something practical
there was nothing but there is there is
no doubt about it but well riding riding
a bike swimming driving a car is
something for everybody knows that it's
practical so there's no ok there's yeah
driving car maybe a little bit of theory
but in general you acquire the skill by
of practice by practicing and the thing
is that no matter how good and detailed
my father's instructions and lectures
and physics are I will never ride a bike
through that method I will have to make
mistakes and be patient and do it every
day now why am i talking about bike here
riding a bike and learning a language
are two different things but they're
both what they have in common is that
once again it is an ability speaking a
language riding a bike is an ability
that you acquire it is not a subject
that you study
now I think that the main problem within
the school system and I refer to every
school system in every part of the world
with very few exceptions and that's cool
we are forced to study a language as we
would study biology history geography
etc but languages are not supposed to be
studied they're supposed to be seen as
something acquired through practice like
playing soccer for example it is not
just trivial disquisition on words you
know study you learn but that's more or
less the same thing behind the word
studying behind the world the word
learning there is there is actually a
big difference and a big difference in
the approach and big difference in the
outcome now I would like to tell you a
story to students let's suppose that
they're Mark and John these two American
students and they decide to they had
they both get hold of a Brent new
language course both happy and excited
about it they want to embark under a new
language quest now mark he is he's got a
very analytical mind so he thinks the
best way to learn a language is
considerate like an object to study he
divides that into fragments so to say he
thinks that by dividing it into sections
he can actually understand it quicker
and more quickly for example what he
does is he dedicates one hour to grammar
one hour to pronunciation when I were to
making lists of words and
and more activities he learns texts by
heart he thinks that's a best solution
he revises Wars etc he is treating a
language exactly like you would treat
geography history device things into
sections and and I think this is not
actually the best way now let's suppose
to John on the other hand he is
conscious of the fact that learning a
language is a means of learning skill he
always has that on his mind and when he
does is he delves into he tries to find
interesting content interesting in that
he can understand he has a double he has
a bilingual translation he gets old of a
simal book for example and he treats the
language as a unicum as a block he
doesn't divide things into the
pronunciation exercises grammar etc he
just reads and listens to interesting
content a lot of times and he considers
that learning a language is done by
absorbing it he doesn't do any kind of
rote memorization technique nothing of
that sort no list that's as far as I'm
concerned that means to learn a language
to get it into you by exposure and by
finding interesting content now if
you're still wondering what starting and
learning what the difference is between
signing and learning you I just wanted
to add that in 1996 it was my first
self-study profile study a tenth and was
German that was fifteen I got hold of a
dusty book my grandmother she was
passionate about languages as far as as
as well as my aunt and I just decided to
learn German the
old fashioned wait that is I hadn't
previously never learn a language by
myself so I just learned French and
English at school well studied them
actually and so I thought that the best
way was just to grab a grammar book and
try to figure out the rules after a
couple of months was a little bit
frustrating I told myself I'm never
gonna make it this DDoS daya the verbs
it was complicated and then I got I just
found out that there was this
dadless teeny course and I just I just I
just applied my technique on it the
bi-directional translation and what I
did is just listen and read a lot and I
found it interesting because I was
passionate about German and then I was
applying this technique and I was not
concentrating on grammar on on tables on
pronunciation
everything was just one block so I was
using books and I do advise and I do
suggest people use books but you know
was deliberately learning but not
stunning anymore I was not stunning
anymore I was not treating German like a
subject I was treating it I was
constantly I was conscious of the fact
that I was learning something by trial
and error and I was absorbing it and
that made a huge difference and what
also made a huge difference and I will
talk to you I'll talk about it in them
in another video is that it is not just
what you do not oh not only the actions
that you perform but also the time
schedule and the times casually is
extremely important that means that
means the time did you choose to make
certain things instead of others it is
very important too for words to stick in
your memory it's called una fiesta in
pour aller time window and I will
explain what it means later so thank you
very much for listening to me and hope
to see you in the next video
why